>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> It's my pleasure to introduce
the author who respects food,
who respects his customers and
respects local Washington DC.
Spike Mendelsohn has written The
Good Stuff Cookbook, it's as warm
and friendly, family friendly as
his restaurants, so please welcome
to the National Book
Festival, Spike Mendelsohn.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Thank you, thank you very much.
It's an honor to be here.
You know, if you asked me a couple
of years ago if I thought I'd be
up here being presented as an author
I'd probably say, you know, no.
You know, I'm a chef at heart
and I've been very lucky
in the past couple of years.
For those who don't know,
I obviously film the reality
TV show called Top Chef.
Are there any Top Chef
fans out there?
Wooh! You know, we have
an all star season.
We just got them filming,
so that was really exciting.
I just got back yesterday
from New York.
It was really, really intense
and it should be a great
season for you guys.
But, you know, after filming
the show, I wanted to open
up a restaurant that, you know,
was very fast, casual and kind of,
you know, gave [audio cut]
that watched the show,
so I didn't really want to open
up a fine dining restaurant with,
you know, tasting menus
and you know 20 seats.
I really wanted to open up
a restaurant that I can kind
of invite everybody in and focusing
on classic American food and,
you know, just doing it really,
really well like taking
the hamburger
and just making it something
a little bit healthier to eat,
something really super fresh.
And, you know, with a lot
of luck and a great location
on Capitol Hill, you
know, we did that.
We opened up Good Stuff Eatery
about 2 and a half years ago.
You know for the-- who-- how
many people have been there?
Yeah? Wooh.
That's only half of you, so the
rest-- the other half of you,
I expect you to walk up
the hill a little later
and check the place out.
You know, and the great part
about this concept is is
that it really kind of--
you know, I was new to DC.
I was very worried
leaving New York City
to come open up a restaurant in DC.
You know, I didn't have
too many roots here.
My sister had lived on the
Hill for a couple of years.
But the greatest thing about DC and
Capitol Hill especially is the sense
of community I've developed
over the last 2 and half years.
[Inaudible] You know, I owe most of
my success obviously to my customers
and the people that support
me on the Hill and it's just--
it's been an amazing
ride and, you know,
we came out with the idea doing
The Good Stuff Cookbook because,
you know, at Good Stuff Eatery it's
very family focused, it's very farm
to table focused and it's just
like a great feeling and great vibe
when you go to the restaurant.
And I kind of just want to
share that with everybody
that didn't have a chance to come
to DC and come to the restaurant,
and that's why we came up
with the Good Stuff Cookbook.
So, you know, it's
the whole entire menu
at Good Stuff plus
another 150 recipes.
The great thing about the book is
I draw, you know, our inspiration
from a lot of my friends and you see
that because a lot of recipes there
that [audio cut] to it and I
think that's the greatest thing
about the book.
And, you know, it's
also-- it's very--
you know, the cookbook that we came
out with was very easy to shop for.
So, any of you can find
any of these ingredients
at any local supermarket and,
you know, at a minimal price
and just come up with
a great fun meal.
And, you know, the most
important thing about the book is
to get people involved
and invite friends over
and for everyone's
hands to get dirty.
So we're really happy with the Good
Stuff Cookbook and now I'm an author
so I could check that
one off on my list.
You know, are there any
questions out there?
I mean, I'd like to keep this
open to questions and-- yes.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> It turns into soup.
I'm so happy you asked
me that question.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Okay, I was told to direct to
the microphone where there's two
on each side for questions.
Although the question was--
she's saying that my recipe
for my toasted marshmallow milkshake
does not work in the cookbook.
But-- no, no, I was just kidding.
You know the funny thing
is that it's kind of--
if you're using a Vita-Prep at home,
you're creating friction and heat
because it's not really made
to kind of spin milkshakes.
At the restaurant we use the
old school Hamilton Beach
that has a prong that doesn't
kind of create friction.
You know, the best thing I
could tell you is probably leave
out the milk and just work
it just with the ice cream,
like melted ice cream and
then the toasted marshmallows
and then just blend that together
and then it won't get it soupy.
Yeah, okay.
>> I enjoy cooking but my interests
and my creativity waxes and wanes.
How do you maintain your
creativity and interest?
>> That's a great question.
You know, I maintain my creativity
and interest and I just keep it--
and for me, for myself, I keep
it really, really seasonal
and I get inspired by
many different things.
You know, I was in Europe
for the last week and I got
to go eat around everywhere.
And everywhere I kind of went I
got inspired by a certain type
of ingredients or flavor, so I
was like, "Oh, maybe I could--
you know, maybe I can do that at
Good Stuff Eatery, or maybe I can do
that with a pizza or apply that."
But you know, I also-- you know, I'm
standing here alone but, you know,
I have a huge support group in
the restaurant and it composes
of my parents, my sister and
a couple of my best friends
that I kind of forced to
move from New York City
to come open my restaurants with me.
And you know, it's just kind of--
sitting around the table
shooting ideas out,
and I think we mostly relate
on our experiences of travel.
You know, when we're coming out
with new menus and we're trying
to be creative, we always kind
of look back on, you know,
first like where we've worked, what
molded us to be that type of chef
and then through, you know, our
travels through Europe or Asia
or even New York for
instance and kind
of what we've picked
up along the way.
So, you know, for me it's just like
life is just an inspiration everyday
and I kind of apply that towards
food and what I do, so thank you.
Yeah.
>> Where is the hat?
>> The hat, the hat.
I have to ditch the hat.
I'm trying to grow out
my hair a little bit.
[Laughter] I hope it looks good.
I don't know.
You know it's-- I've been wearing
a hat straight for maybe about 2
and a half years and I just went
on the all star show and I kind
of wanted to move myself
out of the hat
because I do get that
question a lot.
But I still have plenty of fedoras
and I will be wearing
throughout my life but I just feel
like I need my head to
breathe a little bit this day,
so I got a lot going on [inaudible].
>> I'm embarrassed I haven't
been to your restaurant yet
but I've read all about it,
and can you talk a little bit
about the meat that you use--
>> Sure.
>> Do you get it locally
and [inaudible]--
>> Yeah, absolutely.
So, you know, we get everything at
Good Stuff within a hundred miles.
You know, our meat is out of the
farm in Virginia, it's grass fed.
You know, I have a-- you know,
that's the greatest thing here also
for me and I think I owe a
lot of my success to it is
that I have really great
relationship with all my farmers
and my purveyors and the
people that supply me the food.
And, you know, we're
not buying cheap things,
so you know they really allow me
to work on the prices of the food
that I get from them and then
so I can offer something
reasonably priced for the clientele.
So-- yeah, and my meat's
my own blend.
You know, I spent maybe about 3
months traveling to different farms,
visiting different butchers and
kind of creating my own meat.
It's a little bit of short
rib chuck and sirloin.
It's about 75 percent
to 25 percent fat.
And it's uniquely ours so--
you know, I really enjoy it.
I think it's tasty.
I think it's got great flavor.
The most important thing
to me about our meat is
that you can just really
apply salt and pepper to it,
give it a really nice sear,
proper cooking technique
and it's just delicious.
I'm not one of the guys who like,
you know, folding shallots or butter
or blue cheese into the meat
or any kind of that, you know,
sauteing onions, just
a personal preference,
but our meat comes from Virginia.
Which way am I going here?
>> Hi, I actually work at the
Library of Congress and we go
to Good Stuff and my co-worker
go to Good Stuff and We,
the Pizza almost everyday
or twice a week--
>> We, The Pizza, have you
guys heard about We, The Pizza?
Yeah? No? Okay.
>> And my question is when we
walk in there, it's blaring.
I love your music selection, and
it's like blaring Jay-Z and--
>> And We, The Pizza?
>> And so-- and We, The Pizza, yeah.
>> Sure.
>> And then Good Stuff has bought
R and B. What was the inspiration
or why did you choose
to use that music in?
>> Well, the probably blazing
Jay-Z 'cause I haven't been there
for a couple of weeks but--
[ Laughter ]
>> Oh, I just told
him that, I'm sorry.
>> No, I'm kidding.
I just went to the Jay-Z concert.
I love him.
But, you know, the idea of--
well, for those who don't know,
we just opened-- I recently
opened a new restaurant called We,
The Pizza about a month ago.
It's focusing on New York
style pizza, homemade gelato,
homemade sodas, again encompassing
like really fresh ingredients,
and we do sell by the
slice which people seem
to be really excited
about on the Hill.
But the great question about
the music is that, you know,
at Good Stuff we actually
started with a rock and roll.
We play a little bit of reggae
and, yeah, we play some R
and B sometimes too but I really
think it's important to kind
of set the ambiance of a
restaurant so when people walk in,
they're getting an experience.
>> Sometimes again trouble
for how loud our music is
if I don't control it, but I just
feel like it just uplifts people
and makes it interesting and
there's a great environment.
We chose a different
style of music for We,
The Pizza because it was my business
partner, Michael Colletti and I
and he's really into hip hop
and we really wanted the store
to be a little bit hipper
than Good Stuff here,
like Good Stuff here was
a contemporary farmhouse,
so it's very homey, it's
very family oriented.
We, The Pizza is the same thing.
It's really actually inspired
a lot more by our charities
and the work we do around the
community, but we just wanted a kind
of a different feeling
like, you know,
we just thought pizzas a little
bit hipper than burgers and--
>> Yeah, I love it.
It's so much better.
>> Do you love it, yeah?
>> Yeah I love it, yeah.
>> Do you get down with
the rocking, you like--
>> Yeah, I actually
do, I actually do.
>> Cool.
>> So, thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> I'm a student at American
University here in DC,
and I'm taking an agriculture
course, so I have kind
of an academic question for you.
Why is it important to eat locally
and know where your food comes from?
'Cause we're talking a lot about
how we buy food in grocery stores
and we don't necessarily
know where it's from
and that's a major
component of your restaurant.
So why is that important I guess?
>> Well see, I mean first off,
I think we've come a long way,
you know, from where we were
maybe like 20 years ago.
We seem to be like a very food
germ society and people really kind
of wanna know where
their food comes from.
They kind of wanna
build that relationship.
I think first and foremost, you
have to support your local farmers
and the people that grow these
locally grown healthy foods.
You know, the thing about buying
food from supermarkets is not bad
and it's never gonna go away
obviously, but I mean a lot
of the stuff is really not seasonal,
a lot of the stuff is
sprayed with pesticides.
I mean for instance, you know,
I much rather buy locally grown
tomatoes that have full flavor
than the ones that they pick
in California that are green,
they spray with ethanol, they go
in a truck, they ripen all the way
down here and it's really not done
in like-- in a natural process.
And I'll tell you, you know,
a tomato that's locally grown,
that's organic, the flavor is
not even comparable to a tomato
that gets, you know, picked
green and sprayed with ethanol
and then traveled, and
bruised and, you know,
I just feel like people are, you
know, kind of really wanna form
that relationship and
it's definitely better
for the local farmers here and
supporting the local businesses.
So I think that's why
you wanna try--
not that you'll be able to shop
everything locally but you kind
of wanna try do as much as possible.
So, does that answer
the question, yeah?
>> Yes, thank you.
>> Cool. There's no one there.
>> Oh--
>> I begin to--
>> There should be but
there's no one there yet.
>> I'd be interested to know
what does influence the CIA had
on your career.
>> Sure, huge influence.
You know, I was a little--
I was kind of lucky.
I was a kid growing up in
the restaurant business.
I come from a long line of
restaurateurs from Montreal.
You know, we even-- my parents
moved to Spain when I was 13
and had 16 restaurants in the
World's Fair there and I truly grew
up in a restaurant family.
You know, I was dishwashing at 13
years old, I was a fry cook at 14,
I worked all around the kitchen
and it came to a point in my life
that I kinda-- just kinda
want to refine my skills
and see what I had compared to
people that really wanted to be
in the business and that's why I
applied at the CIA and I went there.
You know what the CIA did for me
just kind of brought it together
and it really inspired me the most
because before I went to school,
I had just grown up in the business
and you watch your parents growing
up in the business and they work
all the holidays, all the weekends,
they have very limited time off.
It's kind of like a scary
career choice as a child.
You kind of want to do everything
but be in the restaurant business.
When I went to the CIAA, it
kind of really solidified
that I had a natural talent.
You know, I was not better
than anybody but I was
so much more experienced in the
kitchen than a lot of the students
that were in my class and you
kind of just reflect on yourself
and you're like whoa, wow.
You know, I do-- I do have
one talent that I'm good at
and I'm a little bit ahead of the
game so that really inspired me.
The CIA really inspired me
to go after the, you know--
to work for the best places,
work for the best chefs.
After my experience in
the CIA, I went to work
for Thomas Keller in Napa.
I went to work in Vietnam for a year
for a very famous Vietnamese chef.
I went to work for Sirio Maccioni,
which is a famous Italian
restaurateur in New York City.
So it kind of just
really motivated me.
And, you know, you go to
school to get a degree but most
of your training and your experience
and the way your career is gonna
develop is working in restaurants
and it just gave me
a really great base
and it gave me a huge
networking pool.
There's not a day that goes by that
I don't run into somebody that went
to the CIA or I don't get a call
from someone that went to the CIA
and that's kind of really what
it brought to the table for me.
Yes?
>> I'd like to know where you stand
on if you have to make the choice
between local and organic,
because you can't always be sure
that you're getting both.
>> Right.
>> I'm leading towards
wanting to buy organic
because I don't want the pesticides,
but if you shop locally at markets,
at local farm markets, I am not
quite sure how you find out for sure
that they're pesticide-free?
I don't know how to
ask that question.
>> No, sure.
I'm not quite sure I know
how to answer that one.
But no, it's just-- you
know, it's funny this--
the organic way that
we're on, it's--
there's a purpose for
it and it's for--
I feel that you can apply that
to proteins and you know a lot
of obviously vegetables and stuff.
But, you know, if you had that--
like I don't think you
necessarily have to kind
of pick one or the other.
I think locally grown
product is grown properly,
you know what I mean.
It's healthy, it's fresh, it's
seasonal, there's nothing wrong
with that product and apply to--
I think they're two
completely different things
and you can apply organic foods,
you know, most of the time
but you don't really necessarily
have to buy it all the time.
Buying stuff that's
really farm fresh
and locally grown is really great
and you're really supporting
the community by doing that too.
So--
>> Okay, thanks.
>> That's it.
You guys are done?
Come on.
>> No, I have another question?
>> Top Chef all star questions?
No one?
>> I have a Top Chef question?
Can you talk a little bit
about that experience?
>> Sure.
>> You know, was that horrible?
>> It was so horrible.
You know the-- actually
the top chef experience--
it was funny, I was working in New
York City for about 3 or 4 years.
You know, I had traveled
across the world for my career,
I learned all sorts of
different cuisines and, you know,
all of a sudden this reality TV show
comes out and a lot of my friends
and family are telling me like oh
my god, you have to do this show.
I wasn't really quite confident
100 percent with the show
in its first couple of seasons.
I kind of waited till the 4th season
until it started growing some legs
and I saw it being really recognized
and appreciated by my peers
and the chefs that I respect.
But I mean I could sit up
here and tell you that,
that show completely
changed my life.
It's funny that it took a reality
show to kind of super launch me
into like my career but it
did and it's a great venue
for any young aspiring chef
that really want to [inaudible],
you know, make a name for himself.
The funny thing about the
business is that there are
so many young chefs these days
that are getting recognized
prematurely like myself.
You know, it used to be you had to
pay your dues for at least like 20,
15 years in the kitchen before
you even start getting recognized
or appreciated as a chef.
I mean you look at Thomas Keller,
like one of my favorite chefs,
a gentleman that I worked for
and I look up to, you know,
really didn't start
making a name for himself
until he was 40 years old, you
know, with the French Laundry
and he had worked, you know--
broken his back for many,
many years to get to that point.
So, I feel very fortunate that
I kind of got that jump start
in my career, you know, on a show.
Also, it was just a
smart way to do business.
You know, if I wanted to kind of
market my restaurant and get a lot
of publicity, I-- you know, I
just kind of "branding" myself
with the Top Chef, open up a fast
casual restaurant on the Hill and,
you know, a little bit of
luck and you have success.
So, I owe everything to that show.
Oh, 10 minutes.
Just--
>> How long is the day at Top
Chef, like when you're competing--
>> How long is the day?
>> Yeah, like one of
the days when you're
like have the final
competitions, when they had you
and you had judges table
and stuff, I mean how--
what time you wake up and what
time you're just finally over?
>> Well, you wake up at like 6--
6:30 in the morning and
usually don't get to bed till
about 2 or 3 in the morning.
It's a full day-- it's I mean.
You know, the greatest thing about
the show that it's, you know,
I get a lot of question is it real?
Are you coached?
It's 100 percent reality.
We're not coached at all, but what
they do is they give us a really
tough schedule and
sleep deprivation.
So it's-- you know, once
you get started and you're
in the competition,
you're going out at--
you know, for as long as you last.
The show itself probably takes
about a month and a week to film
and that's before the finals.
They stop short of the final
4 or 5 depending on, you know,
what they're deciding on doing and
then they cut and edit the show
and then maybe within a week left
of the show they get everybody back
together and they film the final.
You know, just for the sake of it,
there's a lot of-- you know pe--
the bloggers out there and
a lot of spoilers out there
and they don't wanna kinda
ruin the results, so.
>> Okay, it's on.
I'm sitting here thinking
you must have started
when you were 12 years old.
>> Yes.
>> So, what do you have-- what do
you think you'll do in the future?
Because you're so young now and
you've got a long life ahead.
>> I'd like to get to the
moon at some point or so--
>> Would you-- okay.
And open a restaurant?
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> You know it's a-- I think that's
a great thing about, you know,
that I'm lucky about my business
that I could kind of keep it fresh
and I can kind of take on new
projects and keep it interesting.
You know, I have Good
Stuff Eatery and We,
The Pizza now on Capitol Hill, I'd
be really happy to see a couple more
of Good Stuff Eateries open
up across the United States
so I'm working on that
and eventually I really--
you know, I'm enjoying
the fast casual concepts.
You know, I kind of plucked my
way out of the kitchen working
from morning to night
and it kind of, you know,
all of a sudden I'm
becoming a restaurateur
and I'm designing restaurants,
I'm designing menus,
I'm paying attention to branding, so
it's been a huge learning experience
for me in the past
2 and a half years,
something I never really did before.
Usually I just cook food
and let everyone else
take care of that stuff.
Now, I'm getting to build my
brands and build a whole restaurant
from the ground up which is
really interesting to me.
What I would like to do is I would
like to get back at some point back
in the kitchen with an apron on and
working the line everyday and kind
of being creative, that's
kind of what I love to do.
It's kind of what I
miss about the business,
not that I'm looking
back in any way.
I feel very fortunate I've gone
to travel all across United States
and I'm having a lot
of fun with my contest.
But I kinda wanna open up like
a nice cute 40-seat restaurant
when it's appropriately time,
so that's probably what I'll do.
And for the meantime, I'm trying
to work a lot with the charities.
I'm trying to really support
Michelle Obama's Let's
Move Campaign.
You know, we're planning
rooftop gardens
at KIPP Academies everywhere in DC.
I get to go do demos with kids
and teach them about healthy food
and how to cook and
I really am enjoying
that part of my life right now.
So I want to do a little
bit more of that
and then probably open
another restaurant soon.
>> With Top Chef, how different
is what we see on TV compared
to your experience both
with the other contestants
and between you and the judges?
>> Well, you know,
they only use maybe--
I think it's like 5 percent
of the filming that they take.
It's pretty accurate.
I have to admit.
It's a-- they do a really great
job of capturing the story
but sometimes you miss some things
like for instance if, you know,
maybe-- you know, say there's a
lot of great constructive criticism
on one of your dishes or you know--
but they only air the part
that Tom Colicchio said, well,
this dish was flavorless,
you know I--
it's just, sometimes it takes some
of the judge's words out of context
and they use them and then it just
doesn't look too great about you.
They're like, "Whoa, Spike cooked a
flavorless dish, he should go home."
You know, so it's-- you don't get
to hear the whole entire story
because sometimes there are
things that happen in the kitchen
that the camera just misses
and-- the [inaudible] oh my god.
The saga continues.
You know, I think you took it.
I think you took the [inaudible]
it's, you know, it's a-- it just--
I didn't get a chance to
watch the reunion show.
I think I'm sure you got
asked a couple of questions.
I'd be interested to
watch and see what he said
but he looks pretty guilty to me.
Yes.
>> Hi, I just wanna know your
favorite dish and do you plan
on expanding into Virginia at all?
>> Yes, I would definitely be
very happy to expand to Virginia.
I'm just looking for
a great location.
You know, I have heard the
Shake Shack is coming to Dupont
and I hope none of you
go there by the way.
If I see any of you there--
and my favorite dish?
Can I go with cuisine probably?
My favorite dish is kind of hard.
You know, my favorite cuisine
is probably Vietnamese cuisine.
I got to live in Vietnam for about
a year and study the cuisine.
I had also opened up a
restaurant in New York City
that was Vietnamese-French fusion.
But I'm a simple eater.
When it comes to the-- the kind
of food that I like to eat,
it's very minimal,
very simple ingredients
and that's pretty much it.
I mean I like-- you know, if I
could pick one, I love [inaudible].
You know, it's a spicy
broth beef soup.
I just think it's great, it's got
lots of herbs in it, green sprouts.
A lot of different textures, it's
got a lot of great aroma to it
and it's like a great meal so--
>> And one last question
related to Top Chef.
Do contestants really
listen to their--
to the judges' criticism
or does it just go
in one ear and out the other?
>> I think most of the
time, with me it goes
through one ear and out the other.
You know, I respect all the judges
on the panel especially
the guest chefs.
And I'm just joking
with you, there's--
the thing is that it's
such an intense show
and sometimes the odds are so
against you and it's so difficult
that it's just like, you know, you
can just mess up just a little bit
and they're gonna make
it a huge deal
on television because they have to.
>> Yeah, it is very subjective but
as an audience, a lot of the times
or most of the time from my
perspective, I tend to hear comments
from the panel and I just
roll my eyes like whatever.
>> Yeah, exactly.
Well, yeah, when Padma says
anything I'm like whatever.
[ Laughter ]
>> It's like you took
like a half a bite.
No, I'm kidding.
I love Padma and she's
come a long way.
You know-- you know, when
she first started the show,
it was a little iffy.
I think she's really educated
herself and worked hard to kind
of talk food and know about food
but sometimes like it's just--
it's really, really weird
what comes out of her mouth.
>> Thanks.
>> Sure. I think we've got
time for two more questions.
We're in overtime.
Do we have time for
two more questions?
One more question.
Okay, you're gonna have to
pick the person [inaudible].
Come on, just two more
questions, there's just two people.
>> Real fast.
>> I've been watching Just Desserts
and it's got a totally
different flavor or feel to it.
>> Yes, that's good.
>> Are pastry chefs
really that much--
>> Crazy.
>> Okay.
>> Pastry chefs are crazy.
I think that's gonna be a hit
show because they are nuts
and I think we'll be
able to see that soon.
Yes.
>> I actually have three
questions so I'm gonna say them all
and you pick the one
you wanna answer.
>> Okay.
>> The first one was what
was the hardest thing you had
to do on Top Chef or endure?
What was the funniest
thing you encountered?
And how-- since you've been
both a contestant and a judge
in this season, how do the chefs
compare between the two seasons
that you were on and you judged?
>> Oh, I think I like the
last question the most.
You know, it's-- I guess it's
a school yard pick mentality.
I mean it's-- some seasons
you're gonna end up with a bunch
of great chefs that are gonna
really make a great show and mold
and then sometimes you're gonna end
up with a season that's
just a little slightly flat.
Do you know what I mean with that?
I mean they're still--
I love the show.
I love watching it but sometimes I
think the New York season was maybe
the flattest season of all for me.
I don't know if you guys remember
it, it was Hosea that won.
I just didn't think
there was much to it.
I think they could have done
a lot better job with New York
and they have with
the all-star show, so.
>> Yeah, I'm looking forward to it.
>> It should be good.
>> Thanks.
>> And so I just want to finish off
by thanking everybody for coming,
I really appreciate it, for
the support and everything.
[ Applause ]
>> It's been an honor to be here,
thank you very much
[inaudible] for having me.
And for those who haven't come to
We, The Pizza or Good Stuff Eatery,
literally just follow
these people right
up the block and you'll
end up there.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.